hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm and I wanted to go
over a nice little trap that I saw not
too long ago in a chess game so I want
to talk about some of the key points in
the trap and some of the things you want
to think about if you do see it it's the
blackburn shilling trap and it comes
from the italian game the town game
starts with pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight to
f3 for development Knight to c6 for
development and Bishop to c4 now from
here you'll see a lot of common moves
you may see Bishop to c5 for the gioco
piano but the more uncommon move that
we're going to talk about today is
Knight to d4 now from here blacks
already completely disregarded one of
the opening principles which is don't
move one of your minor pieces twice if
you don't have to and that's exactly
what he's done
from here White's has this pawn on e5 he
can take but that's the trap and so I
recommend if you do see this to play one
of two moves Knight takes on d4 or the
move actually prefer better is King
castles King side as you can see here
White has two development pieces
attacking the center White's attacking
this pawn on f7 which is a huge weakness
for black and at the same time he has
King side safety black doesn't have a
whole lot going on as far as development
so if we completely disregard this
gambit on e5 White's going to have a
very good game but black would really
like white to take on e5 so that's what
we're going to talk about today on the
trap if Knight takes on e5 then black is
now going to play Queen to g5 if he
doesn't play Queen to g5 he wasn't
setting a trap he was just a completely
terrible chess player and you should win
easy anyway so from here the Queen is
attacking this knight on e5 and he's
also attacking this pawn on g2 not a lot
of times white from here since his
Knights being attacked will take on f7
with his knight as you can see his
knight can't be captured because his
bishop on c4 is covering it so the King
can't capture at the same time he's
attacking this rook on h8 he's also
attacking this Queen on g5 so from here
black can completely disregard this
Knight and he can take on
- now if white tries to hold on to this
rook by f1 he can't move g1 because then
we could just take it but if it moves to
f1 then black can come to e4 take check
and then why it has one of two moves he
can bring his Queen to e2 where we can
take with our knight or if he doesn't
move his Queen to e2 then he can bring
his bishop and from here we can actually
play Knight to f3 and checkmate you
can't take our rook his King can't move
this is smothered mate he can't take our
knight on f3 because of our Queen here
so be sure be sure if you do see this
that you don't fall for this chap now a
lot of times you may not see I do want
to go over some of the other variations
if we do play on g2 now if white plays
his knight takes on h8 now from here we
can take this rook on h1 now from here
they only move his kids King can't come
to e2 because of our knight the bishop
can come to f1 now our queen can capture
on e4 and from here he has two options
if he captures on e - or excuse me moves
his Queen to e2 as you already know we
can capture with our Knight if he
doesn't if he instead moves to e2 now
now this is not going to be checkmate if
we move our Knight to f3 but instead we
can bring our Bishop to c5 and put a lot
of pressure on this f2 pawn we're going
to eventually have a lot of attacking
going on against the King and this is
going to be very good for black so I
just want to go over some of the
variations that you may see now the
other move that you will see instead of
Knight takes on f7
which is the better move if white does
fall into this trap the better move is
to play Bishop to f7 check as you can
see here not only can we not capture
this bishop on f7 but we have to move
our King now from here after the King
comes to d8 from here the best move from
Y it's going to be Castle kingside
remember this Queen on g5 is still
attacking this pawn on g2 so we'd really
like our King to be in safety if your
whites your we really want a Castle
kingside
now from here the Queen's going to
recapture on e5 so as you can tell
already from this example white is down
the material and that's if they play
correctly after they took on e5 now I do
want to talk about a few points here a
lot of times from here you'll see Bishop
take on g8 and the rook take on g8 after
the capture so from here blacks up in
material but black can't castle on
either side so for now his black King is
going to be near the center on d8 and at
the same time White's going to have a
nice little center with his pawns he can
he can push his pawn to c3 and then
thrust forward with d4 so white does
have a little bit of advantage as far as
his pawn development but at the same
time a lot of times in chess a lot of
players if they get down to material
they can't fight back so just keep this
in mind if you like the King being open
and d8 not being able to castle anywhere
then you may actually want to accept the
game at the beginning and take on e5 but
if you're one of those players that gets
down to material early and falls into
traps pretty easily I would not
recommend it only because if you don't
take the trap and you Castle kingside
earlier you're going to have a much
easier game than trying to fight back in
this position from being down to
material so if you do see this trapper
want to play this trap these are some of
the things you definitely want to keep
in the back your mind when you play it
so hope you guys enjoy this video if you
haven't already please subscribe and if
you haven't checked out the website
awhile WWH s website comm thanks for
watching everybody